[Musique]
c'est le séisme politique de ces
élections législatives
89 candidat du rassemblement national
sont deux députés le 19 juin
marine le pen triomphe sur les marches
du palais bourbon
[Applaudissements]
le moment est historique pour ce
mouvement politique restait jusqu'ici à
la marge du débat parlementaire
nous avons suivi la campagne de trois
nouveaux députés
trois figures du rn dont le destin
s'écrira désormais dans l'hémicycle
tout le monde a voté rassemblement
national personne n'a vu sa main qui a
pris feu ya plus de freins et maintenant
légende aucun problème à bien social et
la main discuter avec où souvent les
gens me disent moi mon choix c'est soit
je suis plein du réservoir ch soit je
fais le plein du frigo quoi voilà on en
est là en france en 2022 ça fait mal
avant ces élections le rn ne comptait
que huit députés aujourd'hui le parti
s'est doté d'une assise territoriale
bien plus conséquente
quelles sont ces circonscriptions qui
ont basculé et pourquoi
plongez au coeur de ces nouveaux fronts
où les troupes du et rennes ont livré
bataille
[Musique]
la gironde n'est pas le premier
département qui vient à l'esprit pour
évoquer la montée du rassemblement
national
en 2010 est encore marine le pen il
faisait moins de 30 % au second tour de
la présidentielle
pourtant les rives de l'estuaire sont
devenus en quelques années une nouvelle
terre de conquête pour le parti nous
sommes à trois semaines des législatives
et pour la première fois le département
pourrait bien envoyer une députée rn à
l'assemblée
edwige diaz la candidate peut croire en
ses chances et bienvenue avec 58% pour
marine le pen au second tour de la
présidentielle sa circonscription paraît
mûre pour tomber dans l'escarcelle du rn
sur la mobilisation est très importante
surtout dans une légistatives où on sait
que malheureusement il ya beaucoup
d'abstention donc moi en fait mon
objectif c'est que y ait le moins
d'abstention des électeurs et rennes
possible voilà avec la fiche derrière
à 34 ans edwige diaz est une figure
montante du parti
[Musique]
proche de marine le pen elle est
désormais la chef de file du rn au
conseil régional
et rêve désormais d'un destin national
prochaine étape dans cette ascension
programmé l'assemblée nationale cette
élection législative si je devais la
résumer
ça serait bien on n'a pas droit de la
perdre d'autant plus que je vous le dit
marine m'a donné pour consigne pour
objectif de gagner si on perd cette
circonscription si on la gagne pas eh
bien elle va être saccagée on est
vraiment le dernier rempart face à un
danger parce que dans nos territoires on
a quand même beaucoup souffert de
beaucoup de choses des explications des
services publics donc perdre du pouvoir
d'achat etc et donc on ne peut pas
donner les pleins pouvoirs un accroc
voilà en tout cas merci beaucoup
le discours a donné le ton le pot de
l'amitié qui s'ensuit tourne à
l'avalanche de doléances c'est une
france à bout de nerfs qui s'expriment
comme ce chauffeur de bus san polo bleu
manifestement excédé
toiture rien sinon c'est toi convenir à
grasset et je crois pas défendu par
delahaye harrachi
moi je connais pas une profession qui
musique elle va bien les chauffeurs de
bus les contrôleurs de bus les policiers
les aides soignants dans les eaux qui
tourne à bella c'est levitte les
viticulteurs les pompes hier en fait
rien ne va pas je me dis que si on n'a
pas suffisamment de députés
les gens vont souffrir atrocement comme
si l'anti macro nisme débridée permet de
garder les trous mobilisés il ne suffit
pas à créer une envie de rassemblement
national pour cela la candidate le sait
elle doit sortir des réunions militantes
et s'imposer dans le paysage local
marché fête champêtre compétitions
sportives pour le rn plus question de
vivre caché
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sa campagne la mène la
citadelle de blaye
pour une exposition de voitures de
collection
la voiture préférée
comme à chaque visite de terrain la
candidate donne l'image d'un nouveau et
rennes glamour et avenant vous allez
bien ça va oui oui toujours toujours
très bien les oui j'adore votre jauge
est presque le même en vert kaki voilà
voilà alors là faut faire donc je joue
là ça va en plus c'est à sortir marocain
repas trop trop chaud vous êtes superbe
assez gentille on est un parti tout à
fait
banalisée dans le sens où quand même il
ya une majorité du coup sur le secteur
de personnes qui votent pour nous les
gens d'ici sont des gens tout à fait
normaux aussi vous savez ici on mange
pas d'enfant la lui la nuit tout le
monde a voté rassemblement national
personne n'a vu sa main qui a pris feu
on tape un peu trop sur les gros deal
extreme grotte oui alors qu'on n'est pas
du tout l'iphone droite quoi
c'est nos adversaires politiques qui
disent qu'on est de l'extrême droite
la fameuse dédiabolisation du fn semble
ici à un stade bien avancé elle est
indispensable
un vote d'adhésion bravo à vous en tout
cas aussi de faire du terrain
quand on est élu voilà quand on est mis
sous quand on est élu de la république
il faut fait sur le terrain
toujours exactement jour partager nos
valeurs exactement voilà bah bravo en
tout cas bravo bravo à bientôt
déjà candidate en 2017 edwige dias
prépare cette élection de longue date
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tous les
candidats et rennes
[Musique]
le parti mise aussi sur des parachutages
avec des figures politiques qui ne
viennent pas des circonscriptions c'est
le cas dans l'oise une autre terre
convoitée
philippe ballard est un ancien
présentateur de jt sur une chaîne d'info
il n'a rejoint le parti qu'en 2020 et
vient ici en mission depuis paris ah
c'est une terre où on espère bien
conquérir une circonscription est
absolument
et moi ce qui me plaît dans cette
circonscription la deuxième de l'oise
c'est qu'en fait c'est un concentré de
tout ce qui est arrivé comme mahler si
je puis dire au pays ce talent et on
nous a vendu une mondialisation qui
devait être heureuse et qui est un vrai
cauchemar et ce sont des gens qui sont
complètement délaissé par les pouvoirs
d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient de droite de
gauche du centre ou bien ou bien de ce
truc un peu lunaire qui arrivent et qui
s'appelle la ma chronique
qui a moins d'inflation bien france
actuellement si la suisse dans cette
circonscription marine le pen a fait 58
% au second tour
bon tout le monde est en forme i pour
transformer l'essai philippe ballard
doit aller chercher les voix village par
village j'aurai plein de coffre
le voici à noailles ici le tractage
commence sur le parking des régates et
c'est l'oeil de la lilloise des
automobilistes c'est par hasard
bon bah c'est classique 1 c'est le
tractage mais là moi je viens de faire
le plein là parce que évidemment dans la
ses conceptions 110 euros
voilà et pour des gens qui gagnent le
smic ici on est obligé d'avoir une voire
deux voitures souvent les gens me disent
moi mon choix c'est soit ces périodes et
gérard ce soit je fais le plein du frigo
voilà on en est là en france en 2022
le pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème de
campagne numéro un du rl depuis la
présidentielle
mais les vieux fondamentaux du parti
n'ont pas complètement disparu voilà
j'ai vu les images au stade de france la
face et des conseils a340
délinquants qui sont dus des cités
voisines pour agresser
notamment les supporters anglais péter
d'accord c'est ce que vous la subissez
ici
n'attends pas parlé on n'entend pas
parler
rihanna ça peut arriver et les
agriculteurs qui sont victimes de vols
de matériel sur les tracteurs des gps
qui sont qui se font voler puis les gens
sont quand même informé ses arrières de
l'athénée quoi penser à son intelligence
donc on voit que ya le communautarisme
qui se développe partout ils savent ce
qui se passe à roubaix ce qui se passe à
trappes ce qui se passa à vénissieux ce
qui se passe à marseille dans les
quartiers nord donc voilà ils veulent
peut-être aussi se prémunir en votant
rassemblement national c'est pour ça
qu'on fait des sports paris ça fait peur
on a beau dire voilà on n'est pas
rassurés pour combien de choses une
agression gratuite toutes les 40
secondes en france un celi chiffres du
ministère l'intérieur on peut se faire
tuer pour une cigarette refusée un
regard de travers c'est la france orange
mécanique on l'a vu au stade de france
et quelques jours ouais bon faut
remettre de l'ordre
dans l'oise cela fait plusieurs années
que le rn obtient de bons scores mais
cela ne s'est pratiquement jamais
traduit par des sièges de députés
la situation est similaire dans le
nord-est voici une autre cible du
rassemblement national la vallée
industrielle d'ailleurs j'ai florange
c'est la france des hauts fourneaux
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt ou le chômage
reste élevé laurent jacot bélie un cadre
du parti lui aussi en mission surplombe
le champ d'une bataille politique qui
s'annonce intense mais j'aime bien venir
ici parce qu'on voit on prend un peu de
hauteur en fait et on voit la réalité
dieu de ce territoire qui est hayange et
la vallée de la fensch c'est une région
qui a été la victime de cette
mondialisation chevelu qui a été la
victime de la concurrence des
entreprises étrangères qui produisait
loin et à bas coût ici c'est difficile
de comprendre qu'on a bossé toute sa vie
dans des entreprises que l'état a laissé
fermé sans rien faire en disant bas on
peut pas faire autre chose dans cette
circonscription marine le pen a
rassemblé 52 % des voix au second tour
de la présidentielle
ce nouveau scrutin s'annonce serré
mais le rnd tient depuis 2014 la ville
die anges seize mille habitants
alors pour l'emporter laurent jacot
belgique compte bien s'appuyer sur le
maire fabien engelmann et ben oui voilà
donc
on va faire un petit tour sur le marché
il l'a d'ailleurs choisi comme suppléant
et sur ses tracts c'est lui et non
marine le pen qui figure au premier plan
a été réélu au premier tour à 63% il
connaît bien le terrain il connaît bien
les gens et sont un atout ce genre
serait une folie de ne pas utiliser cet
atout là dans la campagne
c'est toi qui me guide voyageurs on peut
aller jusque là
c'est donc en duo que le candidat et le
maire se rendent au marché
voilà vraiment béthune
paul et son 10e à emmanuel macron à
l'assemblée emmanuel macron sans
surprise est la cible prioritaire mérite
de nous il ya tout il ya notre programme
et puis surtout pourquoi il faut pas
laisser les pleins pouvoirs à maquereau
supputait rhénan web à jupiter c'est
plutôt narcisse 1 celui qui se regarde
dans le qui se regarde dans le miroir en
permanence
mais à la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon est arrivé devant le président
alors la gauche unie en prend aussi pour
son grade
je me demande ce qui est le pire on en a
à choisir entre eux on va regarder oui
mais il est venu passer ses cd fois le
burqini désarmer la police
comme le candidat n'est pas franchement
en terrain hostile au pouvoir tu joues
mal at il est allé sur les marchés aussi
placé marshall et ici aussi l'entreprise
de normalisation du r n est bien
enclenchée même auprès de la police
municipale
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'il ya encore quelques années un tel
accueil pour des candidats et rennes ça
paraissait impossible oui oui mais je
crois que nos élus de terrain comme
fabien engelmann ont montré que entre la
caricature qu'on faisait de nous et la
réalité il y avait un gap que l'image
d'épinal qui avait de nouer et casser
parce qu'elle est fausse et qu'il ya
plus de freins et maintenant les gens
n'ont aucun problème à venir me serrer
la main à discuter avec ou
arn banalisée sans doute dans ces
circonscriptions mais attention pour les
candidats à ne pas tomber non plus dans
l'excès de confiance
retour en gironde de bon matin au
village de cubnezais la candidate est
vif diaz et son équipe arrivent en tenue
de sport
ils viennent participer à une marche en
solidarité avec l'ukraine
l'occasion à nouveau d'occuper le
terrain
sauf que l'équipe de campagne ne va pas
vraiment faire dans la discrétion
selphy tee shirt à l effigie de la
candidate c'est trop pour certains
participants à ce rendez-vous à
politique
la présence à la normale et les
citoyennes
ça va nous prendre notre alité c'est
important surtout qu'on défend une cause
essentielle est majeur et quand même
situation dramatique en érable et
surprise
voilà que débarque à son tour la députée
sortante de la majorité présidentielle
candidate à sa réélection
véronique à merrer
vous n'êtes pas bien tenu non j'ai pas
dû l'être injecté dans la députée donc
voilà je suis la gentillesse des faits
après le bon jour glacial
l'affrontement politique a vraiment pas
de toupet parce que je il me semble me
semble quand même que les députés
européens ont voté contre les
subventions à l'ukraine au niveau de
l'europe donc le fait de vouloir aller
marcher avec ce type d'association je
trouve ça totalement antinomiques mais
c'est la politique politicienne de
madame diane dont la ceni vient dès le
début du conflit en ukraine marine a été
très clair elle a dit que la position la
décision de monsieur poutine qui était
d'envahir ce pays souverain c'était
inexcusable impardonnable et
injustifiable
pour les trois candidats que nous
suivons c'est maintenant l'heure du
premier verdict des urnes
au premier tour tous arrivent en tête 39
points 42% pour nvidia
34 92 pour philippe ballard dans l'oise
et 35,18 pour laurent jacomelli en
moselle
[Musique]
la victoire semble à chaque fois à
portée de main mais attention les
campagnes de second tour sont les
cueille historique du rn
quand il frappe aux portes du pouvoir le
parti se heurte souvent à son fameux
plafond de pn
on va essayer d'avoir des débats à
l'assemblée philippe ballard poursuit
ses allers retours entre paris et l'oise
le candidat tracts dans un village un
peu endormi quand il presse soudain le
pas il vient de repérer une zone qu'il
intéresse tout particulièrement un
lotissement oui parce que c'est vraiment
la classe moyenne en fait qui habitent
là donc celle qui est entre le marteau
et l'enclume en quelque sorte c'est à
dire que soit disant tu sois disant trop
riche pour bénéficier de l'aide est par
contre qui et mata matraques et de taxes
voilà et puis les d'impôts donc ça nous
est généralement way très favorable très
favorable
et les faits ne vont pas le démenti
dans la france des pavillons le rn à la
cote bonjour moulin tracks philippe
ballard je suis candidat du
rassemblement a pas d'accord ses
ouailles reconnu alors bon bah
on espère courante pour les français
d'accord ben faut y aller dimanche tu le
candidat du rassemblement national
merci si on les a on est en tête avec
35% alors dimanche prochain on peut
gagner la circonscription
c'est pas normal que ce soient toujours
les petits les classes moyennes qui
payent l'addition quoi donc voilà on
fera un groupe avec marine l'assemblée
voilà pour vous défendre bonne journée à
revoir chez ses électeurs déçus par les
politiques le rn veut incarner une
nouvelle voie en opposition à une forme
de caste qui monopoliserait le pouvoir
ces gens là en fait c'est ils sont tous
interchangeables ils sont tous
interchangeables il croit à la
mondialisation ce sont des mondialistes
ils sont pour le multiculturalisme etc
etc donc ce sont nos adversaires nous
allons les combattre et globalement ils
savent que leur monde et est en train de
s'écrouler face à soi aux par rapport
aux scores qu'ils font nous on a une
vraie dynamique eux n'ont plus du tout
de dynamique
la stratégie est bien connu elle
s'appelle le dégagisme mais pour
l'emporter philippe ballard va devoir
contrer une autre recette politique anti
rn 7 fois le front républicain
et aujourd'hui c'est edouard philippe
qui est venu l'incarner
[Applaudissements]
cette circonscription à enjeu
l'ancien premier ministre et à beauvais
pour soutenir la candidate de la
majorité
dernier rempart face à philippe ballard
j'invite l'ensemble des électeurs à
faire front et l'ensemble aussi des
partis politiques à le faire moi j'ai
toujours closes du blick am j'ai
toujours considéré que la france
sa vie mais quand elle s'est abandonnée
à l'extrême rap
et donc je le fais sans aucune espèce de
l'agressivité
à peine edouard philippe reparti c'est
au tour de jordan bardella le président
du fn d'arriver pour soutenir son
candidat
la bataille de l'oise prend une
dimension nationale
fini a dit militer dans ce café pour
soutenir la candidate qui effaçait
monsieur ballard et porter la voix du
front républicain quel est votre
réaction face à
ces extrêmement ringard comme manière de
faire de la politique
je pense que le front républicain est
justement de voter pour le rassemblement
national dimanche moi je vois manuel
macron qui panique qui semble découvrir
les problématiques de pouvoir d'achat
sécurité à quelques jours des élections
pendant ce temps en moselle
laurent jacobellis à toi lui affronter
une candidate de la france insoumise
parmi celles ci il faut montrer qu elle
sait pas répondre
[Musique]
au téléphone il distille des éléments de
langage à ses équipes vraiment insister
c'est pas la gauche voilà
républicaine laïque bon c'est vraiment
l'ultra-gauche à dist tu as deux choix
le chaos le bon sens en fait donc le
chaos fiscal le chaos social le chaos
sécuritaire ou bon sens enfin un truc
comme ça bon on a pu le temps n'importe
comment mais essayez quand même demain
de bien marquer seul la tête des gens
le candidat arrive au marché de florange
sur place son adversaire est déjà là et
elle va bien faire en sorte de l'éviter
baron
qu'on soit pas vous passez à mais très
très clairement fraikin
disons qu'au début j'ai joué le jeu de
la du républicanisme donc moi je suis
quelqu'un d'authentiqué on n'a pas le
temps de jouer là bas on joue avec
l'avenir des français c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement fermes et extrêmement
sectaires qui vit seulement voilà entre
communiste entré à dix entre
manifestants s'est passé à la politique
un député cité
le duel est à couteaux tirés
avec 27% des voix pour la gauche au
premier tour contre 35 pour le rn
l'issue est incertaine
pour s'imposer dans la dernière ligne
droite laurent jacot bélie va compter
sur un soutien de premier plan attendu
en mairie d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
discrète en début de campagne marine le
pen accélère à la proche du scrutin elle
multiplie les déplacements dans les
circonscriptions clés
et la huitième de moselle ont fait
clairement partie
elle vient là où ça peut aider à faire
pencher la balance du bon côté bien sûr
bien sûr ouais vous pensez que ça peut
faire des quelques mois qui font la
différence je pense oui j'espère que ce
sera plus que quelques voix d'ailleurs
ces résultats de dimanche nous
permettent d'envisager si l'ensemble de
nos électeurs se mobilisent des députés
a et c'est important qu'ils puissent y
avoir des députés rassemblement national
parce que sinon il ya l'assemblée
nationale on ne parlera plus de
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
quotidiens des français
des députés est reine en nombre à
l'assemblée le voeu de marine le pen
sera bientôt exaucé au delà sans doute
de ses espérances
dimanche 19 juin les français sont
appelés aux urnes pour le second tour
au siège girondins du rassemblement
national it vigia sgs est les premiers
résultats se sont d'abord ceux des
petites communes qui lui parviennent
26 ans passant de 6 8% c'est bien on
aurait pu dire si reconnu la bonne
tendance se confirme vite en gironde
comme en france
ce soir c'est l'acte de décès du plafond
de verre pour le grain au scrutin
majoritaire
qui sont là c'est un ami qui travaille
au siège ajouté qui dit ça et il a tout
à fait raison à une autre castanet celui
de
marine je crois que vous n'imaginez pas
l'émotion qui mène train ce soir nous
allons
edwige diaz est élu
[Applaudissements]
il amanda
personnellement
elle récolte
58,70 % des suffrages
dans l'oise philippe ballard est élu
tout comme laurent jacot billy en
moselle
place du palais bourbon trois jours
après l'élection
les 89 députés du r n ont rendez-vous
pour entrer ensemble à l'assemblée
[Musique]
non je me sens encore ce qu'il en fait
c'est lui
servant 89 10 ultime
en fait on savait que ça allait arriver
ça allait forcément arriver un jour
parce que le travail parce que
l'implantation parce que le sérieux
parce que la continuité et c'est la
seule question c'était quand est-ce que
ça allait arriver
art
tu viens on fait en effet voilà j'arrive
tient qu'aux ch d
navigon un parking j'ai pas encore mes
marques je découvre et dans les
escaliers on se rend pas encore compte
de ce qui s'est passé dimanche soir je
pense qu'il ya un vrai tsunami dans les
françaises voient la lola baï qui doit
nous appeler portail voilà
[Applaudissements]
situation
les députés vont alors traversé la cour
d'honneur et rejoindre l'hémicycle
[Musique]
beaucoup le découvre pour la première
fois sous l'oeil de marine le pen
élu sans surprise présidente de leurs
nouveaux parlementaires
[Musique]
à la faveur de ces élections le
rassemblement national est désormais le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale
ah ça y est ennuyé ouais mon grand
combat moi ce que je me rappelle
l'équipe de campagne et étaient bien
placées ont ferraillé pendant 1h au
parrainage voilà et on se disait mais on
va jamais avoir les 500 pour marc et une
fois qu'on était à sa crainte et 304 304
l on essaie au collier blanche c'est
très clair à chaque mois et là on est à
quelques mètres des buts ça veut dire on
s'enracine tout afin voilà et maintenant
il faut travailler pour arriver à
150-200 de senna avec un professionnel
encore plus qui cap-vert 2027 valladoid
ses plages et goûtent importants comme
ça en groupe institutionnalisée comme ça
évidemment le prochain objectif c'est
les intentions du et rennes sont claires
gagné en respectabilité grâce à ces
nouveaux sièges dans sa quête du pouvoir
ses 89 députés auront un rôle crucial
avec eux le parti rêve déjà de franchir
des 2027 la dernière marche